and right of course everyone loves you
together in la-la land but this this
isn't the first time were you were to
Gangster Squad and but in Crazy Stupid
Love we've even seen you dance together
before interesting pose on me but now
what happened did the dancing didn't go
to plan
in Crazy Stupid Love no oh give me the
dirty dancing lift that's what I mean
yeah well we're meant to do that and
then what happened oh you don't remember
well I remember but I'd like to hear you
[Music]
listen seven years old quick strike
about seven years old I was in
gymnastics class and I was on these
parallel bars that are about six feet
off the ground and I was standing on the
top of the bars and the teacher was
holding me by the ankles and somehow or
other she let go and I was standing on
this bar and I felt myself beginning to
tip forward and I put my arms in like
this and I fell six feet to the ground
and I broke both my arms at the same
time Wow and yeah
and so I so I you know I spent a whole
summer I lived in Arizona which is like
a hundred and twenty degrees which I
don't know what that is until so cold
how'd it cast and all that you know I
was just it was miserable there was the
day before the last day of school anyway
I had internalized this excessive who do
be stupid love I know that we're gonna
do the dirty dancing lift I don't know
however that I have an internalized
phobia of being you know lifted over
someone's head at the height of about
six feet to do the left and Ryan lifts
me over his head and I what did i do
right I've never had this happen but I
imagine if a possum fell out of a tree
[Laughter]
and then it was like a full meltdown I
mean I had like a real meltdown yeah you
had to go across the bed and watch the
watch labyrinth
[Laughter]
stupid and then Ryan commuters like
y'all right and then the director Steven
really y'all right Jennifer Connelly has
a revelation separately what was that
about
oh well just the maturity level really
well I think that they I think it was
awesome maybe a little bit of a mind
game because I would go every day to my
tap lessons which I had never really
done before except for a little bit when
I was like 12 and we would do these kind
of very primitive tap moves like you're
eight years old which is the year after
I broke my arm and I would say every day
how's Ryan doing maybe like oh he's
amazing really exceeding our
expectations like the same thing to me
later so for about two months I just
thought he was the most you know
incredible dancer of all time and I was
failing miserably he put us together and
I was like you know I got this before
yes I could I play a few chords I get my
noe the songs in the movie those are his
hands the entire time he's playing jazz
piano and he learned it from scratch for
the for the film I just think
I think have a choice the director
wanted to shoot all of these musical
sequence in one shot and he's been
dreaming about this his whole life so it
was either shatter his dreams Ryan your
mom she I mean I'm sure she likes
meeting celebrities but isn't it the
gift room is really her thing she enjoys
I don't want to help my mom like this I
will tell a funny story about that
picture though which is that my mom was
convinced that year by her friend that
beehives were all the rage beehive you'd
feel embarrassed and it turned out to be
the opposite it was a natural hair vibe
but and my mom sat in front of Rachel
Weis and her hair was so high that
Rachel had to keep thinking in her chair
and I didn't know what to do because I
was you know I did wanted to have a nice
night so I I didn't know Meryl Streep
but she was sitting next to me and I
said in a commercial break do you would
you would you mind just telling my mom
you like her hair and she was like I got
this and then the commercial when she
goes do you know I wish I was gonna do a
beehive and I wish I
here do you know that story your mom my
mom yeah
that would focus on the early dancing
career of mr. Ryan costing dance troupe
you were in can you tell us about
because apparently young dancers they
could be quite vicious it's a cutthroat
business to get out I I was on some kind
of Canadian Star Search and I somehow
made it to the finals and my main
competition were these two twins who
were tap dancers and they were dancing
to phil collins 2hearts and they had big
heart-shaped bows and they were just
they were the ones to beat so I remember
you know wishing them luck and going on
stage and I was getting ready to start
with dancing the everybody dance now by
C&C Music Factory of course getting
ready to start which is this is how you
started a winning dance number if you
want to know into the just off stage and
the two twins are standing there it's
like the twins from the shining and
they're just going like this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that means war why I just shimmied my
way all the way to it to that trophy to
that tiny little trophy all it's a tall
girl true but obviously it's not you're
in it in it yeah that was the was that
the there was the point that was the
gimmick they let me dance there for free
because I was a guy because if you had a
guy you you would win oh okay yeah so
are you are you ready to see the I
believe you're dancing to Kathy Dennis's
classic touch me
did the troupe of a name right it was
elite dance studio old enough to know
better
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]